hello my name is kosher Asif and elite
Android apps and games marketing today
I'll be talking about how you can keep
your users engaged I'm coming back Larry
Page I'll see you once coded product
should be like toothbrush user should
use them at least twice a day billing
great product is key but to ensure your
users love and use the product it's
critical in a recent survey we found
that forty percent of the users only use
enough for a week nobody wants to be an
app or game which has hundreds of
thousands of installs but very few
active users to avoid this you need to
be smart about marketing and marketing
always start with the product in this
stock we have laid our few basic
principle that will help you keep your
users excited engaged and coming back
for more here are the five rules to help
boost engagement rule number one let
data drag the decisions it is extremely
important that you look at all key
events in life cycle of your consumers
to understand what is working and what
is broken you only can fix stuff once
you know it is broken there are various
tools out there which can help you do
that Google Analytics is one of them the
Google Analytics engagement report helps
you discover how visitors use your app
you can use this set of report to track
wide range of information about your
users including the total number of
screens per visit the order in which
screens are viewed the number of
technical errors and app crashes how
often they return to the app how long
the sessions were how long individual
app elements take to load and specific
content actions which are unique to
Europe like social interaction clicking
on it on an ad or recommendations data
informs your product and marketing once
you have the right data you have
actionable insights to make improvements
and boosts usage the second room is
educate an
for most first-time users installing and
opening an app is like going on a blind
date the first impression is the most
important thing don't assume that users
will figure out how your app or game
works visually explain it to them and
help them get started also tell them how
to get help if they ever need it the
most basic thing you can do is to have a
great welcome screen and build from
there leading to fun interactive
tutorials on screen instructions and
more this is your chance to get creative
test different messages try new things
number three understand the learning
curve every user has a learning curve
and understanding that it's critical at
a macro level it is important that you
talk to the user at the right time for
example if you are a game developer
don't tell users on how to use a new
power play mode which they can only
unlock after 30 hours of gameplay that
said casually telling them that this is
a powerful a mood which they can unlock
is alright fourth principle remind why
users like your app an app is not the
center of the universe for most people
well for some diehard fan it might be
that said to keep user engagement coming
back you have to remind them why they
love your app and what are they missing
out some app developers have used native
Android features like rich notifications
widgets lock screen widgets live
wallpapers to boost engagement
stickiness and constantly bring users
back to the app both is a great example
they leverage rich notifications to push
new stories to the user on the home
screen also it is a great time for you
to remind yourself that the objective is
to keep users engaged and not spam them
these features can easily be an overkill
and frustrating for the user use them
smartly the last principle that I'm
going to talk about is to reward and
bring your users back now that your
product is doing
the marketing for you you need to look
into the final aspect of retention and
engagement for just customer marketing
and loyalty put your existing marketing
channels like social media in a Brevard
mechanism emails gamification etc to use
based on the data you have seen reward
the power users with something tangible
unique and personal it will help boost
the morale to share your messages and
keep them active overall aim to boost
the lifetime value of your users at the
end of the day it is all about building
apps and experiences which you yourself
would like to use and gradually start a
conversation with the user and make the
experience personal I hope this was
useful and thank you for watching